[Música]
vamos a poner otra vez la música eh
yo tiendo a tirar para un lado y para
otro y también te lo digo bueno nos
ponemos en pie por favor que vamos a
hacer algo muy especial ponte en pie y
ahora hay una vocecilla it&c
pues no estaba yo mal aquí sentado
verdad
bien vamos a darle otra vez porque me
han dicho voy a dejar hasta la muleta
que os parece yo soy así
porque no nos parece como cuando bajan
de un avión los Rolling Stones a estas
alturas que se le ve que parece que le
Sansa con féretro
y 5 horas más tarde
están desatados encima de un escenario a
ver que también a lo mejor se ayudan con
algo
no diré yo lo contrario así que voy a
dejar aquí la muleta
[Música]
y me han dicho que hay muchísimo talento
en esta sala así que
vamos a darle un poquito de la música
sí y si no canto yo
son pasos he creado unos pasos super
complejos porque me han hablado de que
tenéis el potencial vale así que seguid
me es muy importante primer paso
[Aplausos]
segundo paso
ahora empiezas a notar como el cuerpo se
te va detrás del ritmillo porque está
diciendo solo los dedillos y las piernas
que
dar un poquito de atención
viernes este viernes
recuerda tus buenos tiempos un viernes
todavía
[Música]
muy bien muchas gracias un gran talento
dile al de al lado da gusto verte
moverte díselo al lado
[Música]
bueno ahora que estabais despiertos iba
a decir yo y levantados a vamos a hacer
una cosa súper disruptiva los que estáis
de aquí para allá veniros para acá
sí sí todos los que estáis por ahí
venimos para acá para hacer más así que
el roce hace el cariño a estas alturas
ya os vais conociendo o no después de
todo el día aquí venga veniros para acá
muy bien además
dicen los que saben de estos que por
delante se aprende todavía más sé que
vamos a practicar la noble ciencia estar
más cerca muy bien a ver vosotras dos me
acercan ya os quería quedar un poco para
allá venga vamos bueno cómo estáis
he ido más entusiasmo en el hogar del
pensionista de mi pueblo cómo estáis
si me gusta en fontanero todo muy bien
bueno pues mi nombre José P García y
para mí es un honor estar aquí con
vosotros cuánto de los que estáis aquí
habéis vivido alguna situación de
incertidumbre alguna vez en vuestra vida
muy bien muchas gracias
y cuántos de vosotros en esas
circunstancias de incertidumbre dijiste
ay ay ay ay
bien muchas gracias y cuántos os
gustaría después de este ratillo juntos
llevarte un algo que va a hacer que la
próxima vez que haya algo incertidumbre
digan algo que le gustaría
pues me alegro para eso estamos aquí hoy
sí que antes que nada muchas gracias por
qué estáis aquí hoy sabéis que la gente
normal hoy aquí no está
habéis no sí que si la gente normal no
está aquí tú que eres
claro especial claro está ordinaria me
encanta estar con gente extraordinaria y
especial porque como bien ha dicho mi
compañero justo antes
quien no está dispuesto a aprender cosas
nuevas y eso supone desaprender lo lleva
porque el nuevo mundo no sé si estáis
percibiendo así que cambia un poco
rápido alguien ha recibido en los
últimos tiempos que cambio un poco
rápido la cosa no hace falta ser muy
astuto para percibir que esto va a toda
leche no así que si nos quedamos donde
estábamos no hay mucho que hacer nos va
a generar una palabra que se llama
sufrimiento alguno de vosotros ha visto
esto es una pregunta también publicada
pero ha visto alguna vez un documental
en La 2
entero he pillado
bien estamos en que llegar hasta el
final las dos y en ese documental
atención estás ya de nota alguno ha
visto cebras
muy bien muchas gracias pues a mí
siempre me ha intrigado por qué las
cebras están en el documental y están
haciendo allí la cebras tranquilamente y
se ve en la propia escena
un león o leona para los puristas una
leona allí a tiro o sea que se la ve que
las cebras están y siguen comiendo
tranquilamente y la gran pregunta para
ustedes señores eminentes etologos en
este gran congreso mundial de tología y
comportamiento animal por qué las cebras
viendo a su depredador natural ahí al
lado no salen por patas porque crees que
es
teorías hipótesis
señores son ustedes referencia mundiales
a ver alguna hipótesis
porque la tienen localiza dice ahí está
muy bien muchas gracias que más
mientras esté quieta podemos ir tirando
muy bien a mí hay una hipótesis que
también me encanta hice mientras la
cebra de al lado corra menos
entonces ahora la cuestión a mí que
siempre me ha intrigado al final
explorando investigando pues descubrí
por qué pasada no y es porque las cebras
tienen un sentido para detectar cuando
en realidad la Leona es una amenaza de
verdad que es una amenaza de verdad
imagínate que están ahí y siguen
paciendo porque porque no sienten que
estén amenazadas pero imagínate que la
León hace así un poquillo y entonces en
ese momento es cuando las cebras hacen
así
los estomas parece un avestruz pero
bueno hacen así y entonces ya se ponen
en alerta preparada para salir por patas
cuando notan y sienten que hay una
amenaza real tonces a ti te cuentan esto
y dice ah vale si esto es así pues te
vas o safari en Kenia con la familia a
ver leones en libertad y entonces estás
allí en la Rober salen a los guías te
ponen allí un mantel de cuadros una
tortilla patatas un porrón unos filetes
empanados para que te sientas como en
casa ya y enfrente una familia de leones
en libertad
y entonces te dicen
tranquilo que si están a distancia de
seguridad y entonces dices tú a Vale
o no
porque que se te pasa por la cabeza
suena el isismo
y si no es una distancia tan de
seguridad y lo giras como saben de qué
vas entonces ya te conocen dicen no se
preocupe que si les preocupa esto vamos
a tener un foso anti leones que ya está
construido donde no pueden saltar los
leones porque es de 12 m y lo que se
conoce del león que más alta de la
historia los Leones de 5 m y entonces tú
dices sí sí
o no
por qué qué te dices a la cabeza y si
el león que está enfrente es
potencialmente el futuro campeón del
mundo donde va a romper todas las marcas
y así empiezas en la espiral y al final
dicen pero es que si salta tal ya te
dicen hombre pero tienes un Land Rover
qué es anti felinos blindado sea
que te subes a la romería y ves a los
felinos a tu alrededor y tú dices así si
me como la tortilla o no
por qué dices no y si voy con lo que voy
con los castellanos y me resbalo en la
sábana y de repente al subir las
escaleras me dejo los dientes que me han
costado un dineral también y tal y me
coge de los ijares me lleva para aquí
para allá
total que por mucho que no garanticen
que esto es así whatsapp tenemos una
herramienta fijado lo que digo
herramienta que se llama la mente humana
que ya se encarga de anticiparte todos
los posibles escenarios a cuál peor que
parecemos vamos guionistas de película
de terror dejamos a Stephen King a la
altura del betún y si alguien ha
practicado la noble ciencia del y si
alguna vez
mira de al lado y le dices tienes cara
ver la práctica o díselo díselo de al
lado ya verás como no te equivocas
díselo no te cortes
muy bien pues esto es lo que ocurre la
mente es una herramienta que si no la
educamos nos va a generar
miedo a lo que está por venir
incertidumbre que crees cuando decimos
incertidumbre crees que es una palabra
que nos evoca cosas buenas y cosas
deseables pregunto si o no
no he oído sí o no
pero fijaos y si pensáramos que la
incertidumbre realidad es futuro por lo
tanto no existe
incertidumbre que no hay certeza la
mente siempre está buscando certezas es
una herramienta que intenta protegerte y
te deja dónde estás yo en el mundo no te
puedes quedar dónde estás porque porque
el mundo avanza cada vez más rápido así
que hay que arriesgarse pero decía
Timothy Ferriss un tío que escribió un
libro que se llama la semana laboral de
4 horas decía si es que la definición de
riesgo que tengo es muy buena decía el
tío dice riesgo es la posibilidad de
obtener un resultado negativo y
reversible qué es lo único en la vida
que hay es reversible pregunto
por lo tanto todo lo restante se puede
reverse ificar
vale así que lo primero de todo la
incertidumbre es deseable
depende de como nos lo tomemos depende
de lo que nos contemos recordar somos
hijos y esclavos de las historias que
nos contamos
así que imaginaos cuando yo me estoy
diciendo y si y si y si es verdad que
eso va a pasar no tengo ni idea podría
decir y si disfruta muchísimo de la
tortilla de patatas con mi familia
viendo leones en libertad ya está ya he
cambiado la realidad que voy a vivir así
que la gran clave de la vida es darse
cuenta tomar conciencia estar alerta
para que me cuento si vamos que según
los estudios dicen que pensamos tenemos
una media de 20 a 40000 pensamientos
diarios
cuánto tiempo te tiras contándote cosas
en la mente al día cuántas horas creéis
te voy a dar un dato irrefutable desde
que te levantas hasta que te acuestas no
paras de contarte cosas y la gran
pregunta es y que me cuento tanto rato
porque lo que te cuentas van marcar tu
interpretación de lo que está por venir
y eso lo cambia todo tiene sentido lo
que estoy diciendo sí o no vale así que
ahora la gran cuestión de todo esto es
que antes a la incertidumbre las cosas
no sabemos que va a ocurrir pero sabes
que pasa que no está escrito y como no
está escrito lo podemos escribir
nosotros y poder escribirlo nosotros
supone que podemos crear en el campo de
la incertidumbre es el campo de lo
posible es el campo de las posibilidades
ilimitadas es el campo de la creatividad
es el campo de la innovación es el campo
del potencial es el campo donde tú
puedes aportar realmente al mundo en lo
que ya está escrito no es lo que está
por escribir si solo que hay que tomar
las riendas de que voy a escribir yo
yo puedo escribirlo si no me lo escriben
sabes cómo es esto
así que ahora se trata de decir vale
cómo convierto esto que va a venir en
una oportunidad
dice que hay una frase que me encanta
dice cuando soplan vientos de cambio y
crisis la mayoría de la gente corre a
refugiarse solo unos pocos construyen
molinos de viento y se hacen ricos
pues hay que elegir vale
te imaginas que llega un momento que has
dicho vale voy a hacerlo así
ahora cómo se hace eso pues muy sencillo
a partir de ahora tu trabajo en esta
vida y por lo menos el mío lo es y desde
mi experiencia personal así os lo
comparto es darte cuenta todos los días
traer a la consciencia que me estoy
contando porque si estoy en automático
sabes qué pasa que tomo las decisiones
de siempre y no sé vosotros pero yo me
he columpiado tengo campeonato mundial
de columpie alguien están tiene algún
campeonato también aquí en la sala eh
muy bien muchas gracias hemos dejado la
mente es una mera herramienta que tome
decisiones por nosotros que haga por
nosotros imaginamos que la mente es como
un compañero de piso o una compañera de
piso que se levanta todos los días a tu
lado y te va contando cosas todo el día
oye mira esto está bien esto está mal
deberíamos hacerlo así deberíamos te
imaginas al cuarto de hora le daría un
codazo y dirección quita quita pues no
no solo nos ha demostrado que se ha
columpiado tantas veces sino que sigue
siendo nuestra principal asesor o
asesora de decisiones es cómo dejar el
coche a alguien que ha perdido el carnet
por puntos 30 veces Dylan en chirona
otras cat y tú con toda confianza coge
el coche
así que vamos a tener que empezar a
las riendas nosotros porque tú no
eres tu mente tú eres el que observa la
mente la mente es la que genera la
incertidumbre en negativo así que en
realidad ahora podemos decidir cómo
convierto en una oportunidad lo que está
por venir y lo que está por venir da un
poco igual sabes porque porque la clave
de todo el asunto va a ser que sea capaz
de
asumir la realidad que eso es lo que no
hacemos nos creamos expectativas nos
quedamos como queremos que sea el futuro
lo que va a ocurrir tal y luego no pasa
porque la vida no es lo que tú quieres
es lo que es y nos falta mucho realismo
hay que asumirlo que tengo la
versatilidad yo tenía este plan pero ha
pasado esto otro y así lo asumo no me
lamento puede haber conflicto pero sin
drama
porque en realidad os voy a confesar una
cosa
la incertidumbre no existe
es un constructo de la mente a futuro el
futuro no existe no está lo único que
tenemos es el momento ahora mismo y el
momento ahora mismo lo que tenemos que
hacer con lo que tengo ahora mismo que
hago no era lo que yo pensaba muy bien
estaba en el pack podía podía ocurrir
vamos a aprovecharlo es decir si a la
vida no decir no esto lo enseñamos y lo
aprendemos en improvisación no cuando
pasa algo que se sale del guión la
mayoría de la gente decimos ay Dios mío
pero los profesionales de verdad de la
vida y de la comunicación dicen ay qué
bien voy incorporarlo esto no estaba
previsto qué guay es el modo viajero de
ir por la vida no de sufrimiento extremo
que es el habitual que elegimos porque
es una elección vale así que señoras y
señores
a mí me gustaría deciros lo siguiente
poneos en pie
ahora se trata de que cuando venga algo
que no esperabas te vas a poner nos
llamamos en modo junco todo junco cómo
es pon así las manos como un junco de
toda la vida eh que vienen mal dadas que
vienen vientos de cambio que vienen
vientos de Cris y mira lo que hace
pero tienes que hacer esto es muy
importante vamos allá es más pides más
porque estás habituado porque es tu
naturaleza dame más caña venga ya tiempo
que no vienen unos juncos tan
maravillosos la verdad
y desde esta postura desde la postura
del junco lo que nos venga es mucho más
llevable y encima lo convertimos en algo
productivo creativo para tu vida así que
os voy a lanzar un reto una acción y es
que a partir de mañana en los próximos 5
días 5 días eh te voy a pedir que pongas
una alarma en tu móvil cada dos horas
para que cada dos horas suene la alarma
y en ese momento
pienses en qué estás pensando y que te
estás diciendo para que empieces a domar
a la mente empiezas a cogerla como una
herramienta a tu servicio y no qué tecla
dice y en ese momento podrás tomar
decisiones funcionales para tu vida
decisiones que de verdad que sean útiles
para tener una vida aquí y ahora qué es
lo único que existe aquí y ahora sí que
el Señor Señor es asumir el reto o no
pregunto eres de fiar o no
me fío
de convertirla en algo deseable y en
algo que es lo que nos ha dado la vida
para que evolucionemos muchas gracias
[Música]